another thing he talks about is
overcoming challenges and the importance
of trauma in particular for men i happen
to believe that having a challenging
life is very important for both men and
women
i think that overcoming things whether
it's financial struggles or whether it's
whatever it is that you've been through
in life i think that you can come out on
the other side a stronger person
a more committed person to what you
believe in
there's nothing worse than someone and
more unattractive frankly than someone
who started out young had a silver spoon
all the money in the world didn't really
have to work didn't really have to be
motivated
isn't really you know it's just like oh
i'll just you know slide by in life
first of all those people tend to be
very boring because they're not
multi-dimensional because you build
those dimensions of your personality
through struggle through trying to get
that apartment and trying to pay for it
and getting that job and working a lot
of hours and realizing it's not for you
and then hustling around and trying to
figure yourself out and going on those
dates and realizing it's not good and
actually not having that financial
cushion to kind of just throw yourself
on imagine walking through life and
there's just a big mattress big old
cushy mattress going beside you that
every time you tripped you fell onto
that
kind of boring a
b you wouldn't be tough c your reflexes
would suck because you wouldn't even
have to catch yourself so much would be
off about who you were just because you
always had that cushion let's play this
what he says on overcoming challenges he
he relates it specifically to men i
understand why he's doing that we'll
talk about that in a second but i do
think it's a valuable lesson for
everybody this is uh 124 21.
i say the best things ever happened to
me are the worst things ever happened to
me all the trauma and [ __ ] i've been
through in my life are the best things
ever happened to me because as a man if
you've not had a difficult life you
could not be good at being a man
being a good man and being good at being
a man they're two slightly different
things but to be good at being a man you
need to be i've been through so much
[ __ ] that when the matrix deletes your
entire life from the internet and starts
lying about you at mass and people start
doing protests wanting you [ __ ] hung
and they're looking for your family
members and reporters start calling
every ex-girlfriend you've ever had
trying to convince them and bribe them
to lie to come out and say you're
something you're not when they're
genuinely out to put you in jail that
you can sit there and be focused and
stoic enough to go you know what okay
what's the chess board what's gonna
happen who's trying to shoot me right
now nobody okay so it's better than it
was a couple years ago okay so xyz and
plan through it right you're never going
to be capable as a man if you've not had
trauma the best man ever have had trauma
if you call a police officer you need a
brave police officer you ain't going to
be brave unless he's been through [ __ ]
yeah
yeah this is and that's 100 true you
know you you want and that's why i think
i think a lot of women struggle to to
really point out what they like about
those guys that that feel like they've
been through it
and oftentimes when i when i would you
know say that i would kind of word it
like that when i was younger and they'd
say oh you're like a damaged guy and i'd
say no i actually don't it's not damage
it's that they've been through it
they've overcome it and you know that
that guy at the end of the day isn't
going to crumble when [ __ ] gets hard
because they've had to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps before so many
times
that you can lean on them and that's
really important i think i really do in
a male female dynamic i think it's
really important for women to feel that
i can sink into my man that i can lead
when time gets hard when times get hard
whatever it may be financial a horrible
loss in the family i like that big bear
hug feeling um i'm not embarrassed to
say that i think that's something really
special about
a male female dynamic so if you have a
guy next to you that crumbles at every
turn that's not gonna work what i love
about my husband is that he's very
sturdy
i can be a little bit when [ __ ] hits the
fan i can be like oh man you know i kind
of like fly away for a second you know
for that minute i'm like this and he's
just like not he's very linear he's very
like well this is what we need to do i
remember i tell the story again during
covid in the initial months i lost my
mind
mostly because i had a small baby i lost
my mind i lost my sanity i lost what i
know about health and wellness i don't
know where i went
remember own up to these moments they're
what make us human you can't become a
better person unless you own up to when
you [ __ ] up
and i remember my husband was just very
like
very stoic about it he was very like you
know walking around he got covered ate
his ice pops went from one room to the
other kind of like uh went to the
grocery store lived his life you know he
did he existed and he was it was he was
untouchable
all of the fear porn and all of that it
just kind of bounced off of him like he
had armor
and that was wonderful it didn't bounce
off of me initially now it does because
i told you i don't like to get played so
now i'm like
i got like that snake skin you know that
and not even snake skin is smooth what
is it porcupine something trying to
think of something that's like
that's how i feel now
but in those months it was very
important because i was like ah and if
he had been
that would have been [ __ ] instead he
was calm and i was just like and
jeremy's just like come on babe it's
fine like here's why it's fine here's
what's gonna happen blah blah blah blah
very very attractive and very very
important men can you imagine a society
if all of the young men
just crumbled
you know just like had
were the ones that were notorious for
panic attacks and i'm not saying don't
don't don't abuse what i just said and
cut a clip saying oh jed says all the
panic attacks are by women i'm not
saying that i'm not saying that but put
a bunch of people in a room i'm just
asking you do it put a bunch of people
in the room and let a spider loose and i
want to know there will be guys don't
get me wrong that run to the corner of
the room but i'm guessing that the
gender ratio on that will be more female
just saying try it try it with a snake
try with it we just have that in us so
we're like you know
and that's okay it's okay i'm kind of
proud of my little like ah you know
because i know that my man is gonna be
next to me like babe it's okay i got it
he goes he gets all the bugs in the
house i do not pick up those bugs i
don't want to pick up those bugs i don't
need to pick up those bugs i got
somebody for that
so what he's talking about here is
really really important and i remember
even for me going through media
overcoming challenges was very very
important but again you can't gut
society you cannot gut society unless
you make men unable to handle the harsh
realities of life you can if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]